sí buenas tardes andrés yo creo que lo
más importante a retener primero es esa
cadena perpetua irreductible para sala
de slam el único sobreviviente de los
atentados del 13 de noviembre y esas
tres cadenas perpetuas que fueron
multadas en penas de 30 años de decisión
que son a todos esos miembros de la
célula terrorista considerados miembros
de la célula terrorista y miembros
activos que ayudaron a buscar los
escondites que se encontraron con el que
viajaron a siria me refiero
concretamente a osama que ayer mohamed
bakali y sofía nayarit que son
condenados a 30 años y no a cadena
perpetua recordemos que para ellos el
ministerio público había pedido cadena
perpetua con una obligación de
cumplimiento de penas de 30 años pues se
las ha dejado finalmente en 30 años de
prisión obviamente ellos todos incluidos
podrán apelar estas penas y
eventualmente reducirlas hay que decir
que las tres personas que comparecían de
manera libre en este proceso seguirán
libres y bueno tendrán que ajustar sus
penas a lo que hoy les ha dado el
ministerio público que en la mayoría de
los casos son penas menores de las que
se les había pedido desde el ministerio
público erika que otras generalidades
podemos decir de este juicio
bueno hoy es un día muy importante no
esto va a marcar la historia de este
país de esta ciudad además esta lentitud
que ha tenido el juez y en general la
corte de entregar este veredicto
obviamente ha marcado a muchas personas
2500 partes civiles que estaban
angustiadas esperando lo que iba a decir
este juez nos lo había recordado más
temprano una abogada este es un caso
excepcional porque las penas son
excepcionales en general en el derecho
francés la cadena perpetua es casi un
símbolo y en el derecho europeo existe
esta pena pero nunca se aplica solamente
en este caso llama la atención porque en
diez situaciones se había solicitado por
lo tanto es un caso que también va a
marcar la historia del derecho francés
aquí todavía hay mucha expectativa en
esta plaza del fin que se encuentra
detrás de la corte es una mezcla entre
personas que están de vacaciones
disfrutando del verano y las víctimas la
prensa y los abogados que están
intentando de analizar lo que ha sido
este veredicto leído en 50 minutos por
el presidente de la corte un texto mucho
más largo pero él dijo que nos iba a
ahorrar no es cierto el tiempo ya que la
espera
y ha sido bastante larga